there are so many stars celebrating
Milestone birthdays this year and I'm
here with celeb dermatologist Dr Anna
guanchhe to break down the secrets from
the Fountain of Youth one tip from stars
is juicing now can we actually see our
skin glow from what we're doing in the
kitchen honestly I do believe you get a
glow from juicing I'm not going to get
rid of all your wrinkles but it
definitely is healthy for you we're
seeing so many different celebrities
trying new things from dancing to boxing
to weight training what types of
benefits can we see with our skin just
from Fitness Fitness is amazing for your
skin it increases blood flow to your
entire body and your skin loves that so
you're bringing more nutrients to your
skin you're also purging your pores what
tips and procedures are you recommending
to keep that skin youthful and glowing
an occasional laser procedure and then
also infrared light or red light
treatments microcurrent treatments to
firm the skin want more of Dr guanchey's
top tips we teamed up with her and rock
skin care for their beauty must-haves
what skin care product are you
recommending actually I was consulted
during the development of the rock Derm
correction fill and treat serum in a
clinical study conducted on 31 women 97
percent had visibly filled lines
instantly and in four weeks visibly
reduced deep wrinkles it is no secret
that skin care can be expensive so is
this going to break the bank we all
would love non-invasive wrinkle filler
for a great price right well you can get
it at Walmart now for less than 25
dollars
[Music]
thank you